alors voilà en mars mars 83 tous les
gens qui nous écoutent je le rappelle
certainement eu des choses à gliwice
vous savez non quand même un jour de
mars 83 tous les journaux les gros
titres des journaux c'était aussi la
fille de frédéric dard alias san antonio
joséphine a été enlevé vous avez versé
la la rançon c'était deux millions de
francs suisses 2 millions francs suisses
qui fait avec des vrais france allait
battre ça fait combien ça 2 millions de
francs suisses a fait 800 millions
maintenant 800 millions de centimes et
on parle de sentiments comme en suisse
pour qu'on nous parle des français n'en
pouvait nous humilier bon alors donc
lave la rançon et drc puis joséphine est
relâché c'est le pardon de vous
interromps mais je vais dire que ce
raccourci quand je l'entends maintenant
la petite est kidnappé la rançon est
versée si vous saviez bien sûr dans
l'intervalle ce qui s'est passé entre
ces messieurs musée de rap que je sais
que tu repars donc évasion et donc la
police suisse fait très bien son travail
elle
une relation grande grippe n'a peur elle
leur trou il a été jugé il ya quelques
jours ya trois semaines il a été
condamné à 18 ans 18 ans de réclusion 18
ans de réclusion
voilà or il se trouve que ce jour de
mars
83 le jour votre fille joséphine est
enlevé et bien vous étiez en train
d'écrire un livre dont vous aviez écrit
132 pages des 132 premières pages de ce
livre
alors je voudrais que vous me disiez
comme ça en quelques mots quel est le
contenu des 132 et bien écoutez depuis
plusieurs années déjà j'avais conçu le
sujet suivant un romancier habitants
gstaad
c'est à dire personnage qui me
ressemblent mais qui n'est pas moi
romancier comme ça que j'ai ce que
j'avais inventé
marié à une femme ayant un enfant dote
d'une première d'un premier mariage
n'aime pas cet enfant il n'aime pas cet
enfant parce qu'il a épousé la femme et
il n'a pas épousé l'enfant est alors l
lagacé le trouble de sa vie c'était à
elle elle lui quand même à l'écart de de
ce couple elle est en pension dans le
drame d'un village même de gstaad mais
il veut pas la voiture du couple c'est
l'enfer et un intérieur du coup c'est
l'enfer la famille bois il ya quelque
chose de détruit là dedans et puis un
jour on kidnappe d'aider des malfrats
croyant que c'est vraiment sa fille qui
nappe de l'enfant et demande rançon oui
alors attendez oui un peu moins vite
c'est à dire que vous racontez très bien
quitter parce que vous aimez la wii mais
moi je veux aller lentement non parce
que c'est la fiction qui n'intéresse
finalement puisque la cvc le roman donc
il y à un comédien comme ça que thomas
mon passion raconte simplement mais
alors ça va être des pigments
ça fait pas ce que vous racontez premier
c'est que vous montrer très bien le
cédant les 132 première page reste
beaucoup dias comédiens comme ça qui est
en train de fomenter son coup et puis
donc ils enlèvent doral s'appelle
d'orage
je crois bien qu'ils soient là mais a
témoigné détail quand même votre votre
écrivain s'appelle charles ii jallieu
oui or vous êtes né à bourgoin jallieu
oui je suis né à jal jallieu je suis né
à jalonner quand même charles ii jallieu
non j'ai pas curieux et enfin écouter
juste après à londres à dire que
maintenant je veux dire que toute ma
carrière a été basée sur un délire
d'imagination vraiment j'ai de
l'imagination à savoir qu'en faire et
comme je sais plus quand vous de la met
dans des livres et tout va bien merci
mais pour une fois j'ai voulu
m'impliquer
c'est à dire que dans mon esprit j'ai
inventé un personnage qui n'était pas
tout à fait moi mais qui vivait comme
moi qui avait quand même des tic etc au
point si vous voulez quelque part bien
sûr que je m'identifie à lui par la
force des choses puisque j'avais envie
moi de m'exprimer de m'exprimer mais
j'avais pensé à la chose suivante c'est
que ce romancier écrivait on le prend il
est en panne ireo une histoire est cette
histoire c'est celle de ma propre vie
c'est à dire qu'il raconte l'histoire
d'un petit garçon un kéké mal foutu
qu'un problème et par flash et il
balance la vie de ce petit garçon qui
est la mienne qu'il est la couverture de
duke et cette photo qui sonne c'est une
photo de moi c'est une photo de ses
photos de vouvry j'avais quatre ans là
dessus le monde voit derrière ces routes
mais voilà c'est votre mère c'est ma
mère et le chat c'est un passeur ça se
passait dans l'ardèche
donc on traversait à l'époque l'euro
n'avait qu'un bac à traille et c'était
le passeur bon alors alors il y alors
d'un seul coup irruption de la réalité
de notre fiction alors irruption de la
réalité c'est à dire que je venais de
dettes des coeurs l'enlèvement par sun
ce comédien raté soraya pour ce pour se
procurer du fric
et kidnappe la petite durement sied
enfin la belle-fille du romancier et
puis il s'est passé cette chose
et bah adhérentes c'est que un matin le
lendemain matin du jour j'ai écrit ça ma
femme est venue m'appeler enfin
peut-être pas exactement le lendemain
matin elle m'appelle en faisais ce que
je sais fine est avec toi parce que je
me lève tous les matins que je prépare
le déjeuner tout le monde avant que le
personnel soit levée elle me dit
joséphine est pas dans sa chambre et
tout a commencé comme ça l'horreur est
entré dans la maison et l'aurore est
entré dans la fiction l'horreur est
entré dans la fiction est entré dans la
maison et à l'eau il ya une espèce de
télescopage du réel et de l'irréel qui
est absolument forcené et je vais vous
dire une chose quand on a retrouvé
joséphine voyez jugent risible quand on
a eut retrouvé joséphine j'avais mon
manuscrit bien sûr en cours et pendant
l'europe pendant ces heures affreuse au
cours desquelles on est assis ma femme
et moi dans un fauteuil entouré de
policiers bienveillant fraternelle et je
leur dis un grand coup de chapeau depuis
la france aujourd'hui je tiens à les
remercier on peut lancer des messages
personnels alors je le fais est bien
entouré de ses policiers nous de prostré
ma femme tu as et une espèce de deux
femmes qui avaient vieilli descente en
envoyer et brusquement
qu'est ce que je disais non mais
simplement je sais pas voulu raconter
qu'ils avaient ce manuscrit
je pense oui alors brusquement ya ce
menu on retrouve non parce que j'étais
parti en dérapage incontrôlé on retrouve
joséphine et j'avais un ami à la maison
qui nous a prodigieusement secondes et
qui est directeur de la tv en suisse 100
du mur je lui dis bien dans mon bureau
vient dans mon bureau
tu va m'accorder un quart d'heure je
veux te montrer quelque chose et je lui
ai fait lire sur manuscrit la rapt de
l'histoire du rap parce que je lui ai
dit je sais que si je termine ce livre
est le jour où il sera publié
on voir à jamais on pensera que je me
suis inspiré de cette histoire pour
faire ce roman et je veux que quelqu'un
en dehors de ma femme puisse porter
témoignage que j'avais écrit ça avant
l'an alors ce qui est alors après vous
donc le musculeux et dans un placard
il ya un sentiment de rejet et galia sel
dépôt vente on a l'impression qu'on a
déclenché la foudre que quelque chose
chez paquet de magnifiques vous choyer à
tous y compris aux diables dans des cas
pareils
alors j'ai fait quoi que j'ai flanqué ce
manuscrit j'aurais voulu le mettre dans
la cheminée mais je n'ai pas mis la
remise à cause du petit garçon à cause
de ces parties de vie de vrais morceaux
de moi qui était dedans c'est une espèce
d'instinct de conservation j'ai voulu
préserver ça en me disant bon ben je le
récupère est peut-être peut-être plus
tard dans un autre livre ses terres et
j'ai laissé dormir ce bouquin dans le
placard pendant un an pendant à peu près
un an pendant 8 mois
et puis au bout de huit mois enfin vous
savez tous puisque vous écrivez ce que
c'est que l'écriture on ne perd pas de
vue enfin ce qu'on a commencé alors
c'était une sorte de tourments c'est
venu me chercher je me suis dit non il
faut que je termine ce livre il n'y a
pas de raison pourquoi je veux
m'incliner mois devant 2 devant un coup
du sort aux mains on m'a volé ma gauche
je vais pas me laisser voler un livre
en somme je résume des choses comme ça
je reprends mon bouquin et j'ai repris
ce livre est là alors ça ça n'a pas été
de la sucrette oui pourquoi
ben parce que c'est épouvantable de avec
une idée pareille en ayant vécu le drame
parce qu'à ce moment là il ya eu
bifurcation c'est à dire que
parallèlement pendant que j'écrivais ce
livre moi j'assistais à l'instruction du
procès de dudu du vrai du green a peur
du vrai tous les jeudis après midi
pendant un an
j'étais dans le bureau du juge
d'instruction et et j'assistais à cette
chose là et moi comme je rentrais le
lendemain matin je me mettais à ma
petite machine à écrire et je tapais
quoi une histoire qui n'était pas pareil
nom qui n'est pas parce que je suivais
mon canevas parce que je me disais je
vais pas non plus me laisser boulotter
parle par la vérité il faut que je
conserve matam il faut que j'écrive mon
livre mais la réalité quand même là
dessus vous assaillir avec violence sans
fin avec une violence je crois que ce
que j'ai trouvé une formule enfin tombée
elle s'est imposée
j'appelle salle mal d'horreur parce que
c'est vraiment l'horreur qui se
précipitent sur ou deux
un matin en plus retrouver son enfant
dans son lit et trouver à la place des
taches de sang et la lettre de monsieur
qu'ils vous demandent de l'argent pour
vous la rendre c'est le bout de la nuit
c'est quelque chose d'indicible j'avais
perdu mon père deux mois avant et gt gt
terriblement traumatisé par la mort de
ce père qui est qui qui a été
merveilleux pour moi eh ben je peux vous
dire et cimentage leur demande pardon
d'un seul coup le chagrin a été stoppé
net s'est élevé à meyrin craint un brin
en cacher un autre
un malheur en cash à noter celui ci
était tellement énorme que brusquement
et l'image de mon père s'est estompée
mais tout de même
est ce que la réalité dans tellement
pressante tellement violente
est-ce qu'elle n'a pas elle nous a quand
même pas parfois guider votre main alors
vous raconte une histoire il ya une
chose qui a dû se produit inconsciemment
je suis conscient qu inconsciemment elle
s'est produite
c'est que on ne peut pas écrire en ayant
vécu ça continue et son histoire sent
qu'il ya des débris
vous comprenez les jets de vapeur mais
parce que quelque part cette histoire
mais par exemple de ce détail qui m'a
qui m'a fait sauter quand j'ai lu ça
c'est également le personnage l'écrivain
vacher question d'acheter un tableau de
dali et vacher je sorte d'antiquaires au
marchand de tableaux qu'il appelle
d'ailleurs ils appellent les queues il
l'appelle victor hugo et il lui dit ceci
certains esprits mesquins chuchote que
c'est toi qui aurait goupillé cette
affaire
mais oui je suis persuadé qu'on vous
avez aimé mais bien sûr que je
l'interdis dire parce que les gens sont
abominables
parce que les gens ont l'abomination à
fleur de peau parce qu'ils médiatement
quoi vous pensez bien à un romancier un
romancier qui ont kidnappe la fille je
veux dire que en étant là ce soir même
je lance une espèce de défi
je viens de sortir un livre sur un rap
après avoir vécu c'est ce rap en sortant
d'un procès on se dit mais en face et
c'est tout ça c'est effarant
et pourtant c'est quand même là c'est la
réalité vous comprenez bien sûr que des
gens on chuchote et ça je le sais on me
l'a répété on va dire mais c'est un coup
de pub
vous parlez d'un coup de pub
parce que si on allait au cul dans la
vie c'est bien joué on vous prend votre
gosse sous votre toit
je veux dire que des coups de pub comme
ça j'en ai quand vous voulez me faire
l'honneur de m'inviter
ils sont de bon aloi j'ai pas besoin
d'aller manigancé un truc
et puis je vois pas pourquoi un type 7
après 18 ans de mitard donc un plaisir
évident je crois oui c'est quand même
d'être très bien alors maintenant
frédéric dard oui revenons à la fiction
oui là dans la fiction donc votre belle
fille la belle fille de l'écrivain est
enlevée et puis l'argent est versé et il
l'a payé loppsi 2 millions c'est la même
c'est la même en ce sens là même ans
c'est la même rançon millions je suis
tout à fait d'accord
ces éléments sont et alors il a retrouvé
à ce moment là et c'est là d'ailleurs je
trouve la très grande force de votre
roman
c'est que parce qu'il a payé cet enfant
il se met à l'aimer écouté pendant des
années la corse a été tranquille c'est
pourquoi c'est parce qu'on l'avait
acheté on l'avait achetée aux génois
simplement et personne ne contestait
rien ça cet effet chez un notaire je
pense
on avait acheté la corse l'alsace
lorraine on n'a pas cédé des siècles à
se battre pour elle parce qu'on l'a
conquérait vous voyez sur des champs de
bataille des gens mourraient pour ça et
bien là je veux dire ça procède du
touchpad une réaction assez assez
semblable c'est que partir du moment où
ce type à payer sept enfants 1
il balance donc 800 millions d'anciens
francs français de centimes si oui et il
donne ça pourra pas avoir cet argent il
a brusquement une espèce de sentiment de
deux poids deux propriétés mais il a
fait quelque chose pour elle c'est une
seconde naissance qu'il a accordée à cet
enfant il l'a récupéré grâce à son
pognon peu importe les moyens mais grâce
à lui
grâce à lui il a eu ce il lui l'enfant
et attention au live elle est à moi
maintenant un peu et elles ont tué sa
fille ça devient progressivement c'est
pas du jour au lendemain mais ça devient
ça devient progressivement sa fille
comprenez ça va être magnifique merci
bon alors
lalor la police suisse n'intervient pas
d'ailleurs c'est c'la roman non mais je
vous dis parce que dans ma tante en
canevas c'est parce que s'il devait
intervenir là dedans alors j'écrirais un
bouquin du double oui alors c'est
l'écrivain qui lui va démasquer le
kidnappeur alors c'est l'écrivain et la
kidnapper c'est un concours de
circonstance sous fait que
progressivement ils sont mais
intéressant parce qu'à un moment vous
dites un romancier qu'est ce que c'est
sinon un homme qui devine oui mais je
crois qu'il ya un petit divinatoires
chez les romanciers
je pense que notre relation je crois que
nous passons notre vie à écrire des
vérités inventé je pense que oui tout à
fait tout à fait si vous voulez ça a été
parfois il ya même des livres promener
quand même est arrivé une fois dans ma
vie doit inscrire un tiers de l'ide de
quelque chose qui m'est arrivé par la
suite que le corps sont les messages
qu'il reçoit je sais ça un poids le mans
s'écoute soit même intérieurement sans
s'en rendre compte
côté médium de quelque chose de soi
vraiment si on raconte tellement qu'il
est obligé à un moment donné de dire la
vérité et elle ça aussi alors on
pourrait penser que le le kidnappeur
démasqué que voilà un livre qui or il va
avoir un apn comme on dit or pas du tout
ça se termine dans le drame is to que le
père fait ce père ce nouveau père va
être victime même à la fin je viens que
ça se termine d'une manière effrayant
dans la noirceur la plus totale de votre
lit dans le désespoir 10 mais alors là
je raccroche avec la réalité parce que
j'ai constaté que un des drames de la
vie enfin tout au moins de la mienne
consiste à voir ses enfants fiche le kop
à voir ses enfants grandir vivre leur
propre vie c'est cette affreuse que je
dis pas ce que vous avez m'objecter que
c'est la vie que j'avais fait autant vis
à vis de mes parents et que c'est la
chaîne et ses tenues
bon d'accord il n'empêche que pour moi
voir grandir et se détacher de moi mes
enfants
moi qui l' esprit j'ai pas de possession
je suis je suis un père
m voyez c'est quelque chose d'atroce et
est ce que je raconte là dedans c'est un
petit peu ce sentiment exacerbé de la
fidh de l'enfant qui s'en va qui vous
quittez qui vous laisse comme comme un
conte sur une île quoi excusez moi vous
la reprenait par l'écriture d'une
certaine façon ça vous encore plus que
la rançon mais ce qui me frappe beaucoup
c'est que c'est aussi le commissaire
san-antonio cayla et qui a produit
quelque chose d'énorme
alors on dirait que d'une certaine façon
ça pourrait ne pas ne pas cesser et puis
d'un seul coup
frédéric dard préface préface the north
et d'une préface monsieur déjà lieu oui
je croyais déjà lieu que ça pouvait
s'entendre littéralement que savait déjà
eu lieu
ah non non non je ne suis pas dans ça je
la garde pour un taux retenus sont à
l'écouté des bases et ça n'est pas exclu
et quelque chose a déjà eu lieu mais
aussi quelque chose et arrive
définitivement je dire que alors il une
autre une autre hypothèse se dire est ce
que vous pourriez continuer indéfiniment
à produire des aventures du commissaire
san antonio ou bien que ou bien est ce
qu'avec cette irruption de la réalité
quelque chose s'arrête parce qu'il est
possible aussi d'imaginer que la réalité
vient et produite par la fiction à la
façon de borghese en tout cas moi je
suis sûr que quelque chose est
définitivement
arrêtez avec san antonio c'est mon avis
se passe quelque chose répond j'ai pas
ce sentiment qu'il va [ __ ] la trouille
la plume entre les gens je ne pense pas
non je l'impression que c'est un autre
juge les san antonio c'est quelque chose
que ça fait partie de ma vie ma démarche
de magny cours en employés on mange on
dort on se couche il se passe il se
passe la vie - j'écris des san antonio
css rivas ne vous a pas été horrifié en
lisant toutes les scènes de sexualité
dans le livre de son antonio la pudeur
même alors oui je pense massages seront
pas parce que quand j'ai lu le livre de
monsieur basse non mais je vais pas
anticiper mais qui est l'histoire d'un
gars qui se réserve qui préserve ce que
vous appelez ça ce moment c'est un bon
alors moi je peux vous dire que l'aja
dispersent
ah non parce que moi au diable l'avarice
[Rires]
enfin l'homme a été choqué par les
cuivres mais l'homme est choqué mais
comment dissocier vous l'un de l'autre
comment dissocier où l'homme de
l'écrivain moi j'ai l'impression que ça
fait ou vous n'êtes pas de moi ce serait
très difficile vainqueur est un
personnage alors que l'homme vit sa vie
à lui
et c'est un personnage qui est en dehors
de lui il est obligé de composer de de
faire intervenir toutes sortes chose
qu'ici qui lui sont extérieurs je pense
bien que dans mon histoire et il y a un
p'tit gars qui me ressemble comme deux
gouttes d'eau à venir bon ce sera magna
questions sont tenues à miss intimidant
parce que cautionnement foot des
complexes hier j'étais avec françoise
xenakis qui m'a dit tu étais avait en
face de monsieur vincenot méfie toi avec
son accent bourguignons qui va pas osé
lui répondre et tu vas te laisser avoir
oui bon mais alors ça c'est la fin du de
la petite préface de frédéric dard est
cependant après vous signé après donc à
présent les normes et la ping joséphine
ce ne fut jamais plus comme avant jamais
plus personne n'était mort d'un aventure
mais quelque chose si alors qu'est-ce
qui est mort écoutez vous connaissez ce
mot c'est ce que j'ai dis parce que je
m'en suis pratiquement expliquée en cour
d'assises pour faire comprendre aux
juristes d'éprouver ce mode de barbus et
dit le bonheur cette chose qui n'existe
pas et qui pourtant un jour n'est plus
eh bien je crois que sans en être
conscient
nous vivions avant dans une espèce de
paix de naples on passa du bonheur sans
trop grand mot mais mais mais une paix à
c'est à ces merveilleuses ma femme
joséphine moi voyez en été c'était bien
tu es dans un cocon est ce que qu'on
éclaté ce cocon éclaté cet incident bon
on a retrouvé la petite on a même
retrouvé la rançon mais c'est plus
pareil
on nous a volé une gosse de 12 ans et on
m'a rendu une gueuse 17 18
parce qu'elle est brusquement en
quelques jours il ya eu une maturité
phénoménal qui s'est opéré chez elle et
c'est une autre enfant c'est une autre
enfant et et je sais pas moi je suis
prêt la gorge je les regarde et je me
disais c'est pas possible je sais que
tout ça aurait eu lieu mais cela aurait
eu lieu d'une façon il tire et ça se
serait située par fractions je pense
alors que la paf d'un seul coup et ça
c'est épouvantable ç'a vraiment j'ai du
mal à me remettre trêve de gaudriole
c'est dur c'est dur assumer 12 sur le
livre les larmes de san antonio
oui parce que enfin je ne tiens pas chez
aller à votre émission 1 c'est pas le
problème mais c'est très dur et c'est en
ce sens excusez moi je pense simplement
qu'il ya quelque chose qui peut changer
des roues sens où un individu serait un
dédale vous savez les dédales qu'on voit
dans les journaux vous vous trouver la
sortie et chaque individu un dédale
strictement singulier et on dirait que
là vous avez trouvé une voix chacun sa
voie donc et et que parfois pour
quelques uns il faut le malheur pour
pour arriver à la vérité
et moi je pense que d'abord vous êtes
vous êtes toujours vrai je veux dire
vraiment san antonio le commissaire san
antonio une partie de vous même comme
moi je suis ce que je crois que c'est ce
qu'a refusé mais l'amérique l'acef afin
de la fiction la réalité vos amis devant
c'est devant cette forme de vérité et
malheureusement pour vous il a fallu que
ce soit par le malheur
[Musique]